all right just getting started here get
in the stream all hooked up I am now
live awesome
everything looks good over here memories
good CPU load good right so I can
minimize you know actually I should keep
that open I'll get rid of you though
hello everybody who's already here we're
just getting set up and getting ready to
get started
how's everyone doing today
okay that good put this up here alright
I'll give it a few minutes so people get
in um and we can give me feedback on if
connection is good or anything like that
be much appreciated or in the live chat
all right let's get I mean I'm just
gonna get right into starting here and
then we'll like chapel as people show up
so to start off we are working on es6
today on same code base as the last one
earlier this week however we are going
to refactoring um there was some issues
with the use strict keyword I did a
little bit of work on my own adding the
use strict word to every single
challenge but then I realized that that
caused errors and it caused a bunch of
linting errors so we're going to go back
through and fix it up and all that
meanwhile changing some of the tests so
they're a little bit easier to
understand I'm gonna start off by just
kind of going through all the going
through all the JSON and then once we're
done with that cuz they little bit of a
faster process if I work directly on the
JSON a conversing to just jumping back
and forth so I'll do all the JSON first
and then once I get that all set once I
get all that running we'll just do a
live Q&A as we work through all the
stuff alright so get some people in the
chat oh hi Jesse
great glad to hear it um coding and
caffeine my favorite remember the last
time I actually got up and got a cup of
coffee but everybody had my cup this
morning so uh I'm good to go
awesome I've got to know it's all
working well alright so let's get right
into the coding here um where are we at
so the last challenge I did was the
destructuring assignment to assign
variables from objects so we made this
this challenge into a function just get
length passing it a string and then we
have the function scoped used strict
definition from there we have the change
code below change code above and what's
cool about this challenge is that we
want the user to return le n as the
variable rather than just like the the
keyword length because I like to reserve
that so the solution here would be you
know you would do const length is len
equals str which is the string up here
and this uses the object in structuring
because string is an object technically
and they have properties like length
hello glad you can join us and so this
is a great way of testing this we're
basically we're like yeah you can we
have a length variable here but we
actually want you to return le n so
that's kind of a hint for people to
going through this challenge some of the
testing features we're still able to
test so this is an interesting one so
the type of length is number is no
longer a valid test because the variable
length is no longer on like global
scoped it's function scoped
so what we can do though is we can type
of the return value of get length and
then we just pass it a a blank string
because that will technically return 0
Sergio asks is the es6 challenges now
live
so a version of them are but they are
very like there may be a lot of things
wrong with them and that's why we're
here today we're gonna refactor
everything and then we're gonna all go
back through it and do some live
challenge completion and just do some
live bug testing i've already done the
first 13 challenges last night and so
we're gonna try to get through the rest
of them right now so this will say the
func let's change this message to say
the function
get length returns a number and then
we're gonna test if the string returns
the correct value and then we're going
to expect the user to have used a the
length is still an assignment great
moving straight on to the next one
and like I said we're gonna go through
everything and then we'll go back
through and actually test this all live
cool
so destructuring assignment to assign
variables from nested objects okay I do
remember this one so let's go ahead and
let's think about how we can function
scope this I believe we could probably
do something as simple as a function get
max of T mrw and then we can't do that
and then we'll go ahead and do a new
line grab the you strict from there face
it put that in there and then we'll go
ahead and grab all this chunk of code
put that in there and I want to return
we should be returning max of tomorrow
so and we need that you need to use
destructuring
idris asks how about using mocha and
chai so yes we could total like this
actually uses an assertion library very
similar to that of a generic JavaScript
testing framework in fact I would love
to be using mocha or chai but or tap or
tape or in turn you know all of them
however because all of these challenges
are in our index in version control and
are able to be deployed anywhere they
wanted to do it in a way that's like
very quick to deploy this
wrapped in JSON so we can't exactly
write full like test liked SJS scripts
which is where mocha and chai would be
great I imagine you could refactor the
free code camp project to do that but I
feel like it would be slightly more
complicated and it would be harder to
like you know drop into multiple
instances and get running but a lot of
the principles of mocha and chai is
implemented here with the assertion
library just very basic you know assert
this statement and then here's your
message to display out to the user so
this should we should be able to pass an
object into here so it'll actually will
pass forecast but this is not so this is
just an argument forecast so they'll be
able to use that we should say what we
call this one local forecast and then
we'll pass get max of tomorrow local
forecast and now that function should be
returning the valid the valid value so
the solution would be the destructuring
here where we want to use like the D
tomorrow and then the sub nesting of Max
and then assign that to the word Max of
tomorrow
now obviously users could like break
this pretty easily and just you know
return whatever they want to but this
test right here this assertion should
should block that because they need to
use destructuring and now this one
method we need to actually test get max
of tomorrow
local forecast cool all right moving
straight on through use the structuring
assignment to assign variables from
arrays ah this is a fun one this is when
you swap a and B I really like this one
so how could we do this properly with
you strict so we're cuz we're
reassigning we could probably keep that
declaration up there and then we'll go
ahead and we'll write this guy and then
that one's now nested in there this one
should be nested in there and then we
will put on the afterburner there we go
that closes it off and we can snag this
guy throw that in there and then yes so
the user should be editing their code
right in here which will swap the values
a and B using you know the a comma B
equals B comma a and that should
actually keep the white the let the
global scope Ami's because you don't
need to reassign it and then this should
all work fine cool let's see what we
have to do it to change any test I don't
believe so because those remain on the
same level mocha chai yeah those are
coffee types but I know they're also
testing libraries use destructuring
assignment with the rest operator to
resign array elements similar to the
last one we should be able to then
declare let array out here and then do a
go go ahead and write one of these snag
they use nope that was not what I wanted
to do there we go
nope wrong line there we go
put that in there put that there there
their array now goes down to here so
this is invalid currently and then go
ahead and write that line um cuz they
should change this yeah I think this is
fine and then that should be good
that's a good destruction assignment and
we're testing for the there we go
not all right that's nice what is that
see this is an issue because if they use
a radon slice they're actually gonna
have stuff between here so we should
only be testing for the array dot slice
because then of course they'd have to
wrap it see we have videos on how to
actually use Jarius unit test testing
framework so I'm making an NPM module I
don't know if free code camp has one um
but I could definitely do one I love
writing tests it's a very important
thing in fact a lot of my contributions
to node J s and react are all the
testing and then the implementation yeah
I actually been working on some like
deployments so like a lot like pretty
like complex nodejs apps and I've been
finding the Travis CI platform as long
as as well as code coverage really
useful and uh making oh setup so maybe
I'll do something along those lines in
the future when I'm working on a side
project and not free code camp alright
let's go on to the next one you see
structuring assignment to pass an object
as a functions parameters okay so this
one uses we just have we're basically
just destructuring inside the function
declaration itself okay so this uses a
very like simplified so we're gonna
expand this this arrow function out a
little bit in fact I'm just gonna
rewrite it because it's a little bit
nicer
Const 1/2 equals and then we're gonna
want to write return stats dot Max Plus
stats dot min divided by 2.0 and then we
want to do closed off that and this is
gonna have the stats variable in it and
then we're gonna say sorry grab that
paste it there we can use function
argument D structuring we're not even
going to keep it where we can put that
here
get rid of this line and I'd like to do
we'll do a do not change this line okay
almost there
and now stats should still be valid
because it's heist because it's global
scoped and half SATs should be very
valid great bohemian City asked which
program am I writing I am currently
writing the es6 challenges for the
upcoming beta free cocaine beta I dress
yes Travis CI is um is awesome it how it
works is it basically watches your pull
requests as well as branches and when
you push code to a pull request it'll
automatically run a a test suite your
it'll automatically run whatever tests
you have written for your application
and then if it passes it'll return like
a green light and if it fails will
return the red light and you can get
github add-ons to like track those
testings in fact I think we have that on
the free code camp platform you'll see
at the very bottom of a pull request
it'll have like the Travis CI symbol and
it's running it's trying to build and if
it fails it tells you that that way you
don't merge anything that would crash
potentially crash the site it's all
that's pretty easy to set up what's
something that's fun that I've been
working on is using Heroku which is like
a web server hosting kind of platform
and I've been working on making like
nodejs
deploys that start off on staging in
Heroku past the Travis CI test and then
auto deploy themselves so that you can
see the like to see the application you
just wrote and if you're happy with what
it looks like in staging all you have to
do is click a button and it pushes it to
production and then you have like your
production update and then all you have
to do is just keep pushing code and
github to the staging branch and then it
does this really nice loop IB again like
I'd be happy to go into that in another
video but for today we're working on
this we are making moves because we want
to get this curriculum
up and running for you guys as soon as
possible so let's check our stuff real
quick type of stats as remains an object
good
the assert that the value returns that
great and get user input assert matches
using destructuring
good alright create strings using
template literals I think we just got to
use another function scope so we'll say
function make list and we're gonna say
array and I'll go down here and add the
closing line okay let's see we can do
here
so we're actually going to want to and
then just do return we don't display
array make lists should return
I think we go like do that you know make
this make people know that they're
actually making a list here of things oh
no like Megan like making a list of of
JSX elements to a tutorial and Travis CI
in the future video tutorial on Travis
CI will come I can that be a lot of fun
to film all day I'll do that not as a
live stream though make sure to do that
as a how is it also my name
pronunciation is eid d wreaths in greece
just the I'm really bad at Sonic so I'd
probably won't probably not saying it
right still but you do BC Greece okay
I'll see how that goes
okay put that one there
this should be fine now all right and I
want to say type of we're gonna test for
make list is an object and has a length
of 3 and then
result display array we don't get that
so instead let's do this so I'm actually
I actually have the solution to this
problem in the in the test code so yay
all right cool
I did get it right you Driss cool nice
to meet you alright let's see one more
time and now we're going to make we're
verifying that the user has this because
this is a like we're literally saying we
want this so this code right here is
doing that just that oh this is replaced
with a word all right we'll see how that
goes
well yeah chatting and chatting and
coding I'm just doing a lot of
refactoring I've been looking at this
code for many hours so it's kind of it's
a lot I'm a lot more familiarize with it
cool this one should be easy we can
probably just pop this in here and be
done with it in fact we can take this
and put it in here and then place that
one above and we should be good to go
with this one let's think
now yes we have our little shallow
equals there's supposedly an assert DP
equals method in here but I don't I
don't know how to use it and I want to
try to rely on that so I'm just gonna
keep my what I wrote on dependencies are
never fun because if something is not
working then it all breaks for you and
then good this I'm asking for them to
remove the colon which is expected
awesome coding is actually fun coding is
a lot of fun okay let's see
okay so let's snag this you strict
variable and we're just gonna slap that
and crap not so I want do not want it to
do
put that come on there we go
cool that should be okay I don't see
anything else to do with this one okay
we're getting through these and then
we'll do some live cube a whoohoo this
is a larger one so we want it we want
them to make the class vegetable ooh we
also want to implement you strict
this one looks like we're just gonna
have to UM you don't like this Oh could
we how would this work I did like let
see nope just the wrong one node now we
do let's see and then can it can we then
assign a class to see within a function
let's see Class C constructor X this dot
y equals x
now something didn't work I mean can I
just reassign see is that a thing
has already been declared ya can't do
that hmm although I can't see anything
clear except the color green is it
grainy or is it yeah I know that the
syntax lighting here isn't really great
it's because it's on all JSON so I wish
it would be better but right now I'm
writing some code down here I cannot
actually move I'll move the FaceCam
things so that you guys can see the code
I'm writing I'll stick this up here cool
so you guys can see I'm trying out and
trying to I'm trying to see how we can
declare like declare like declare a
variable and then assign it to a class
well it's just hex and my monitor freeze
or just me my evan frozen yet sorry
about that before i was writing code
where you guys might not have been able
to see so you might have thought i was
frozen but i was just writing off-screen
but so let's see keep me updated though
if things are still causing errors let's
see what we can do here can I say class
class I what does I do it's a function
but then kind of then C this isn't great
this isn't work I don't like this
they can't run any of these tests could
return a car can you return a class
type of yeah I guess it does it's let's
work on this a little bit more so let's
do so you function X and it's going to
return class class Y Steven what does my
computer setup look like we never get to
look at monitor system setup etc
great question I could actually actually
do a picture and a little angle and
break I'll do a little a little quick
picture and put it on on Twitter but I
actually move around a lot
college student so I've been jumping
around between homes and going to be my
own home and where I go to school so I
actually just have a laptop and I have a
monitor and I just HDMI to the monitor
and then I have a USB mic and an
Ethernet cable and it's pretty pretty
it's pretty not too shabby setup but
it's definitely not as high-tech as some
other people's and then Dinesh says
that's terminal I see in you're working
on JSON yes so right now I'm working on
a terminal it's an embedded terminal
with in vs code I can actually make it a
little bit larger for you guys so you
can see a little bit better but I'm
right now I'm just working through like
declaring a function that returns a
class because we're gonna use that in
the challenge above but we're just
writing it in a node instance at the
moment so we're gonna return class Y and
Y is going to have a constructor that is
going to do it's gonna take in the
character Z and it's gonna say this dot
foo equals Z and then we're going to say
like that should be good enough and we
can close off the class declaration and
then the function declaration and now if
we're going to say what bar equal
oh crap know what if I did you hey is
this gonna work
let's see fuzz class constructor Y
cannot be invoked without new so what if
I did
lat YY equal and then what Versace's do
bar equals new YY fuzz okay okay
what does new YY I do okay cool it does
do that
yeah two monitors helps a lot I can do
I've gotten pretty good at writing with
one when I have to cuz like I said I
find myself traveling a lot and working
in a coffee shop or a plane or a train
or a bus but um definitely there's perks
to having a nice home set up a double
monitor or even triple monitor those are
fun okay we're almost there okay so
let's say we're gonna say recall this
function make class and then within it
clear that if you strict and then we're
gonna grab this line paste that in there
just like you it's not you and then what
we do
returned vegetable okay and then we're
gonna call Const see this is a fun one
we just go vegetable out here and this
is going to equal make class so for
monitor setup now I'm down to three
anything less than that feels weird now
and then Dinesh when you are when you
are coding while speaking it seems like
you you're and you're having a
conversation that's just so amazing yeah
I guess guess it does and then Jesse
said definitely a you stuff okay yeah
was it different for fun once I had like
a desktop and I like tried to see how
many monitors I could plug in and I
somehow got like six monitors all
working and it was just like I had them
all spread around the room like there
was no way to actually get that set up
nicely and it's just like really it was
like really silly but it was hilarious
to be able to be like yeah six monitor
setup uh I'm having a discussion with my
code in myself yeah yeah it is it's kind
of how it goes here a lot of coding is
talking to yourself so this should be a
valid thing
when we say I don't want to mislead them
this is their in the u.s. so let's just
so that and then they should crew put
the class decoration in there okay so
that's one more time let's test this out
down here so we're gonna sell or have a
function it's gonna we're just gonna
call this or actually let me um
clear out node so I get all the
variables back let's go ahead and write
function foo he's going to take in no
arguments but it's going to return a
class X that is going to have a very
basic pun structor which is going to
take Y and return no this dot Z equals y
close the constructor close the root
class close the function and then we
should be able to say go ahead and write
Const x equals foo and then we should be
able to say Const r equals new x we're
just gonna just gonna give it a buzz
you're printing listen and then we
should well to go bards ed yes all right
awesome
that works so type of vegetables
function and vegetable should have a
constructor that's still valid and get
user input assert get user input not
just a class so we want to use class
keyword and then assert that constant a
equals new vegetable apple yeah that's a
fun that was the silly when I wrote in
let's just read vegetable can be
instantiated great
tool what's your what's your questioning
Chris this one all right yeah I love
this one this so this is my favorite
challenge I think in the whole section
use Gators insiders and control access
to an object because it actually is a
little challenging it you have to you
have to create a thermostat class that
has a constructor a getter and a setter
and you have to implement the Celsius
and Fahrenheit I don't grab functions
and it's very like it emulates a sort of
state management that is much higher
level with classes and kind of like you
know more just high level high level
object-oriented stuff but it's really
cool I hope it's not too difficult when
people give it a shot
let's see Dena she just made a function
JavaScript that asked your name and
tells you what your favorite dishes
house it does is it completely random
Dena sure doesn't process like the
characters in the name and make
something off that okay so we're back on
here how are we going to adjust this one
I could totally just use the same thing
shouldn't I just a function make class
and then have it return that out yeah
let's do that
I had to delete that line we don't want
to be mislead go return thermostat
okay and then we're gonna say Const
thermo stat equals make class
I love this this what we're doing here
is really really nice though because we
get to use the function we get to use
you strecht which is really good keyword
cuz it makes sure things aren't over
right in and it throws type errors
instead of just crashing the whole
program and we still get like a standard
constructor and it's not very obvious
cated this is actually very nice syntax
I wonder I wonder if this could be
implemented in other applications to
make things a little bit easier yeah you
got to tell me your your dish first my
favourite food has to be cheese steak or
as the Bostonians like to call it steak
and cheese right now we're on to the
important required challenges so I'm
actually going to leave these because
they're still not working at all and I
don't want to try to mess with them so
we're gonna we're basically done here
with all this so let's go ahead and run
quick let's push our code and we're
gonna run npm run commit and then we're
gonna do fix a challenges and we're
gonna say what did we do
refactor es6 challenges or why
refactored refactored es6 challenges up
to 23 I believe up to 22 because we
didn't do 23 and to use function scope
you strict want to
great breaking changes none none let it
run its thing then we're gonna go ahead
and get push origin fix es6 challenges
okay let's go check over here
no quincy started cueing let's see
so getting error confusing messages all
right
so Quincy's having some issues with is
obviously there's a little bit of work
to do so let's go ahead and start
queuing in these ourselves I wonder what
is going on here though let's go check
that's one of the first ones
okay yes this should all right let's go
see what's up obviously some things are
not working so we're going to debug and
make it all work hey let's add another
one here we're gonna run node seed
that's a database is going running cool
and now we're going to run gulp awesome
okay let's go over here your localhost
3000
and I should kick us into beaker can't
we're gonna start at number one
saved work okay why is this let's reset
here we go
so we should be able just to go over
here and run light and light and that
should do it alright something went
wrong let's check what what it is
earn affected token what's wrong to
function calling it let's see real quick
you know okay maybe it has to do with
the being an arrow function let's fix
that but this should be a valid way to
call the function
maybe we can just do this it's not I
don't even I don't like that syntax
let's just update this let's just say
you know cat function cat talk there we
go
can't talk
and then below this we should just run
run the method cat talk okay let's go
ahead and - let's run those seed okay
we're gonna also go back here and update
Quincy it sounds rainy is it going to
rain on out there
it might uh you guys might be hearing my
fan my computer I wish my microphone
wouldn't pick it up but I don't really
know how else to make it not I'm trying
to place it in front of the fan and that
might help but isn't really not not a
whole lot I can do about there but it
actually might rain outside - okay
working on them lot on these live right
now the error you ran into has something
to do with the function declaration this
self calling function declaration I'm
updating them to look nicer now and
still use and still use you strict it's
important that when you're working on
open source code that you keep the
information on the github otherwise you
know what I might be doing right Quincy
might still be working through these and
if he doesn't receive an update like
this he might be spending the hour
scratching his head so by telling him
that we're working through it and that
this is like what's up he's like alright
cool so he knows what's going on he
knows how to fix it
someone asked can i watch the full
lashing back towards when it's finished
yes you can um my live streams always
get reuploaded it'll take a little bit
the process because it'll be quite long
but they will definitely be there for
you to watch
cool let's go back over here so we've
we've done node seed let's go or it's
just reset okay it's done and then let's
do a nice refresh here let's reset the
code
yep clear it and then if i unlock and
run it should work good because now we
gotta go here
but var does not exist in code that's
confusing
[Music]
oh that's silly
there we go I should probably not write
code at 3:00 a.m. because errors like
that happens
cool refresh that and unlock the code
and it should run and pass good stuff
all right reset please you know what
actually I'm gonna go ahead and I'm
gonna do this how do I have it reset
localstorage oh it's in these isn't it
local storage
it'll lead everything is that a thing I
can do
oh great
I just delete all awesome alright cool
give a nice refresh yes so this browser
guys
the reason I'm able to do that and not
care is because this browser is a dead
browser that I the Firefox dev browser
um developer edition so like I don't use
it for anything professional I just use
it to write code and test code so this
is eight backed stuff right I need you
to back in back no actually this is all
this is very front end a lot of the
syntax you use in es6 will be used in
react and redux and a lot of the
front-end libraries you see in today's
world all this code that you're seeing
right now do that alright cool
I love not seeing any errors over here
because of the nice you stripped so
let's see if our variable does not exist
in the code so we should just do
variable let I and then block scoped
let's run the toss
okay same deal probably I think the
variable message is messed up here yeah
cuz I copied and pasted it okay that
fixes that lets be verbose and check
awesome my computer's doing a lot better
today in terms of performance it's good
to see run this love it alright
yes
alright there seems like there's some
spacing issues let's clean that up
and I know that's not gonna work
let's go ahead and run it anyways just
to see loop protect is not defined uh-oh
[Music]
wonder what that is
no I asked for loop protect not defined
and this looks like it's a free code
camp error let's see
you're an example possible okay well I'm
not trying I don't want to devote so
this is a Firefox issue let's see so it
still gets transpiled on the s5 because
of use of for older browsers
compatibility right yes all right
great question let me talk about that
just for a second here so this whole
section is es6 and everything that is
written everything that we write for the
for free code camp is es6 because it's
the standard it's awesome has some
really cool things but you're right it
doesn't run everywhere es6 is not
currently supported on all browsers the
way we do that is by transpiling it
using babel or something else but i'm
pretty sure we're using babel and when
we do this code you write your code here
and then webpack actually will take the
code chunk from here put it into an
object and then before it transpile it
using babel it actually stores it in a
variable called get user input which is
why we're using it right here get user
input we're passing out that's a
variable and then we pass it through and
we can do should we can do stuff with it
we can test it we can run regular
expressions against it we can run the
code inside of it all normal in es6
because whatever code is executed in
this environment it's transpiled babel
first and then the output is sent so um
when you have words like let and
constant and const they will
automatically get changed mm too far
appropriately through the use of
something awesome like babel right so
i'm having an issue with loop protect
which seems sounds like it's a firefox
error
is not defined on not defined problem on
beta yes
are there experiencing it in Chrome as
well
let's see where did he add this reach
allenge builders that should fix this
I'm going to assign myself to this and
I'm going to review his code in a little
bit
and we're actually going to do live
github stuff okay we're going down the
rabbit hole
I'd like to what is he doing
this looks good to me I'm just gonna say
actually we'll do it over here all day
it was a review changes to say looks
good to me
going to run locally and test with one
of my es6 challenges next and approve if
it solves the loop pro tect issue okay
we will hold off on this for now but
we're gonna make a note of it so what
challenge is this declare read only
variable with the Const keyword where is
that where can I write that I'm just
going to go ahead and just link
everything together to do test with all
right cool
sorry did not want to get rid of that
cool okay back to this let's skip to the
next problem
which one do we just use all right
mutant and ready to clear with Const
let's go
okay how does this one go if we do
coming on please try it yeah okay
same deal here this kind of function
declaration just is not working function
edit in place
okay I should fix this let's go ahead
and run notes seed
refresh
reset clear the code what's wrong ah
missing semicolon
two five seven run it and pass great
okay I've got the same deal here let's
go fix the function declaration
I'm gonna call this function free is obj
cool it's great to reset all we should
have to do is a great object dot freeze
math constants
oh I see
so can we do a can I go try that is this
valid and then when it doesn't work
catch exception and then
math constants is not defined I say
let's see what says so I'm actually
gonna great grab this
okay we're getting there
[Music]
so now
I see such that's an issue
let's return
and then let's go ahead and hear and
write return math constants dot pi okay
and then we should be able to go ahead
and say Const hi equals that I know it's
a little non optimal but all right let's
see how did you get to be the person
that writes the challenges for free code
camp I've been contributing for free
code camp for few months now and Quincy
reached out and said we need to get this
ready to go about Christmas and I know
you know new I know you know es6 and I
know you know how to write challenges so
write all the Essex challenges and I was
like yes let's do it
so now we're doing it just keep that
there and then I had a write assert pi
equals 3.14 message say I want to
actually have this we're going to write
code pi equals 3.14
we set go and let's get right back into
it okay fresh you set yes please
now I'm missing a semicolon okay check
stop freeze
okay I'll fix all that
okay
let's get rid of this real quick
something's going wrong I don't know
what it is
okay let's just try this
how did you contribute to freak okay for
the first place um hmm I don't know what
my first free code camp thing was but I
know I got into just the general
curriculum probably doing some styling
or some basic challenge review and then
I did a lot of contributing for some
other projects like react and nodejs as
well as did my own github stuff learn
more github skills kept up with the free
code camp repository started taking on
some more challenges even began work on
a Python curriculum for a bit
but that has fallen through at the
moment and then from there I
transitioned into the guides platform
pretty heavily doing a lot of review for
that as well as doing some legwork on
fixing some things and you know some of
the some of the backend code for that
set up and then from there I got invited
to work on the free code camp project to
do the challenges Sebastian says typo
question mark um let's see yes you're
right that probably is it
let's see math constants there we go
can't be Const and see I would have
taken forever to figure that one out
that's the issue with writing and JSON
is that you don't get you don't get to
know if your variables like correctly
named or not
I'm just gonna snag this line then reset
the code so I could make sure I see it
no good sleep thanks no errors paste
that in a lock and run
I still sweat I still sweat it spelled
it wrong
where
Oh in my object line
finally all right let's go fix up this
one yeah I don't even know what I was
doing here this is an easy one
we don't even need these we're gonna
change the whole I think basically are
going to be able to change the whole
function here
yep
yes Sebastian the chat is about 30
seconds behind me so sometimes I will
see I'll like you'll you'll see
something but you'll see 30 seconds
later I'll already have seen it but
thank you there for pointing it out just
good enough is that all we need to do
yeah because all they're doing here is
changing it to the other thing
mine is that what so it's not the only
it's not like contributing to open
source does not guarantee a job nor is
it a requirement but it definitely helps
I actually hopefully a blog post should
be getting published soon on the free
code camp publication of medium that
talks about that sure that was me
sharing my experience and how
contributing to open source has gotten
me into has gotten me into my current
internship position and it definitely
does help but it is not necessary and
you can achieve internships or full-time
positions without open source
contributing but yeah as Jesse it's just
just pointing out it is definitely a
very big help
right we're getting through these
thank you
oh well that's not what I wanted but
whatever at this point you've got away
good we're just basically going to lead
up to here
rid of this line
yeah Sebastian's right I talked last
time about how applying your code is a
lot better than just learning it cuz
anyone can sit down and watch a youtube
video over and over over again but it's
until you apply that code wait really
he'll stick and then if you can produce
something even if it's as simple as a
static website but it's written with
react or written with you and then you
know you use Gatsby to bundle it all up
and then you deploy it on Heroku those
steps are monumental to a bigger project
and if you can just show someone or an
employer that like hey I've done this
before
honest much smaller scale but I've done
it I'm familiar with it they'll be like
that's awesome we'll take you we'll
teach you how to do it on a larger scale
and then you'll be you know the next
best thing on this team so yeah don't
ever think that you need to like make
your own face book for it to count like
every tiny small project makes a big
impact just make sure you will talk
about it and talk about the tools you
used and things you learn things you
didn't learn all that kind of fun stuff
or things you failed and learn from all
right function declaration
with you strict
it should be good right let's run this
good and then
cool but I think I want to change this
devar
is it getting an interview or is it
passing the interview Martin because
getting interviews there's that's just
resume and side projects you need to be
able to show them that you've done some
cool stuff through a piece of paper and
you know there's a lot of tips there's a
lot of tips you can get on that the next
step is acing the interview that is a
serious it's a challenge you know it's
not like you're not gonna lock eyes it's
a challenge but there's but there's so
many things you can do and I bet you're
doing him but you just got to keep it up
and keep trying you know working on side
projects and then being able to talk
about them quickly doing that coding
challenges knowing your algorithms
knowing your data structures and maybe
consider starting out like depending on
how much you're shooting for like if you
shoot directly to Facebook or Microsoft
or Amazon or any of the big companies
it's gonna get difficult very quickly in
those interview session it's gonna be
very competitive if you can go with some
you know more smaller teams or maybe
something that's a little bit less
esteem that first work through there and
then apply later down the road that
might go a lot better for you because
it's definitely gonna be easier to get a
job at a different tech company than it
would be to go and work for like Amazon
or Facebook where they have some pretty
intensive interview processes what did I
change here I had to change all this and
we're getting through it
so I'm gonna go ahead and write a
function called square list
getting an interview um resume resume
resume resume it's worth it to take a
class you know see if there's any
programs in your local area universities
do a lot of career prep yeah the the
interview process is that these big
companies can be a little ridiculous
they are they can be quite difficult but
they are changing on when I when I
interviewed with Microsoft I didn't have
to do a single coding challenge so there
is there is times when you can when
those when those larger companies are
changing their ways but it's a way to
show it's the the coding challenges I've
seen are it's it's a way to demonstrate
a little bit of aptitude yeah
preparation is ridiculous I was spending
a lot of time doing that it's definitely
tricky and that's definitely not it's
definitely not the way it really should
be but sadly it is and you kind of have
to play the game and then eventually you
won't have to any longer you know suck
it up and get that first job through the
interview through that horrible
interview process and then you should be
good that's a shame
reach out to the other ones though other
universities sometimes have public
programs too you know they don't a lot
of universities aren't just like for
their students I know mine has you know
they could reach out and they would they
would provide their resources if someone
asked also just general career help I
know there's a lot of websites on online
that have resources all right let's go
from here so functions square lists
passes the array and we just want to
work so we're gonna want to say Const
squared integers
snag this chunk delete all that and
paste that in there
udemy also has some good courses and
they tend to be a little bit cheaper
than Udacity unless some sometimes you
can find the free Udacity programs it's
also plenty of websites - that's who
we're going and you just want to be able
to return this
and then we should be able to say go
ahead and write consul mark I do like
you're actually sorry let's do
you want to say Const squared
oh sorry square list right real number
array but we want to first want to write
squared integers equals
I think the reason why people encourage
you people to go into the development is
because it's a growing industry it has a
projected job growth that far exceeds
other other job paths I know everyone's
really encouraging until you actually
looking to get a job yeah that is uh
that is a challenge and it's kind of
because it's hard then it's back to only
wanting a top percent well I mean from a
professional standpoint you don't really
want to hire people that aren't going to
like do the job well but that said
there's a lot of companies that's still
hire and then they want to teach you on
the job so there's a balance there
anyone can be a developer it takes a lot
of work to get to that like developer
standpoint because you know you aren't
horses you aren't like a full developer
until you're writing code that is being
used by the world up until that point
you're just learning you know I'm still
learning I haven't written anything that
is people are directly interacting with
up until with my open-source work so
there isn't balance between like
learning and you know going for the job
and then while being in a job
Hey we're going with you
okay this should be good to go test us
let's refresh
I remember this correctly which do dot
reduce and then it's accumulator value
and then the return which is number dot
is integer value then a dot can cat V
times V or return a and make sure you
pass in that guy
how is it any different whether it is
deployed publicly for company or not
though and what sense like the code that
I've written for open-source and how
that differ
okay I think I know what you're getting
at the difference is if you were just
publishing code on open source that is
not it is it's awesome because they can
see it but then it's another thing if
you're contributing to currently active
projects because little bits of my code
currently run in nodejs and react j/s
and having my name in those repositories
means something it shows that you know
my code is being used by people and that
tiny factor I think is what employers
really enjoy seeing so if you can if you
can do that basically and get you
nowhere even free code camp that's one
of the I love working on free code camp
because it's a lot easier to get into
and it's a lot it's a lot easier to
teach people how to use it and it means
all the same you know you're writing
code that thousands of people are gonna
be using so if you can work if you can
benefit and work on free code camp that
would do a lot of good things okay let's
see if we run this should we pass
everything yeah but I want to update the
thing over here
const equals equals cool all right
see what it is non simple parameter and
Rick node what
does it not let you do let's see this
all right so
I don't like that syntax though should
out you to travel to
Martin to answer your first thing keep
doing full-stack projects and publish
them on github that are those are great
things to have on there and answer your
second question yes
how looking around just constantly
starring different repositories that I
use and well I know you might not be
interested in a specific repo but if
there's a thing that you use like react
for example I love using react so I star
it and then I look through its issues
every now and then if I see something
that's labeled as beginner-friendly
I grab it otherwise with free code camp
I knew specifically the goal with
contributing free code camp because it
was easy to get into and now I'm making
a big difference writing some really
awesome code maybe in mind that's if
that's what your intentions are you know
just doing it to get better and looking
to get a job then to do it if that's you
know if that's what if that's what your
reasoning and behind open sources then
go for it
you know if you're gonna write good code
and make projects better than doesn't
matter what your reasons I would totally
recommend you go for it and maybe start
with free code camp there's plenty of
challenge there's plenty of issues open
on the free code camp project and they
have a really active contributor channel
could get her channel that they can help
you if you run into any snags I'll send
it setting up or running through the
code
alright let's implement this though how
does that look
so we have our increment equals function
Oh
I believe so Martin that should work
hello how you doing today
Himanshu
okay let's see if this works it's okay
mine everyone's got to start somewhere
I really ko camp is a really good one to
get started with both the beta project
as well as guides have some really nice
open issues
awesome sweet next challenge has arrived
oh how many have we done so far use the
rest operator with function parameters I
don't know which number that is use the
rest operator Wow we've done a few one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
okay cool I'm actually going to do this
one and then take a quick break just two
or three minutes and then we'll get
right back into going to the next view
cool this one looks pretty done so far
let's say I wants me to D structure so I
think this is gonna give another issue
but we'll try it anyways yep
Scizor
Oh same deal
all right we got to wrap it
I want I wanted to ask why too much
JavaScript framework can you clarify
please I'm not sure what you're trying
to ask why why too much JavaScript
framework is there a specific one you're
asking about like react
while it's a great question his mind is
clarified why there's so many um it's a
good question
I think there's mean there's definitely
a point of you know certain companies
built our own and then open sourced it
and said this is what we use you guys
should as well I know like you know
angular started and then Google now
acquires it now Google uses angular all
the time and then react was released by
Facebook and everyone's using it and
then you know people realize that
angular and react were quite large so
they just created their own like view
but there's also some before those like
backbone and ember that all have their
pros and cons but I don't know much
about them to go into detail but
basically people build different
frameworks for different reasons and
then they release them because it's what
they use at their company or whatever
and then the community if the community
enjoys using it then they keep pushing
it yep mine's about right just you know
people make it to suit their own needs
you know react was developed for
Facebook and then people written and
they realized how awesome of a framework
it was and just decided to release it
and now they support it for everyone and
it's turned into an incredible
incredible framework angular has moved
into more of an enterprise direction so
you won't
so you'll see because it's now in full
support of typescript which react does
not but angular is and a lot of larger
companies especially enterprise level
companies like Google and Microsoft
really love using typescript so
angular's direction now is more
enterprise or react is more developer
yeah
playing different differences
see ya
we got to return this yeah I can't
remember I think you just do arguments
cool
okay guys so I just finished this one
let's give me a few minutes and then
just going to be two or three minutes
and then we'll be back to do the next
few actually before I leave let's commit
to github always a great thing to do oh
there's actually a refactor that's
interesting I didn't know that what some
test challenges QA yeah six challenges
yeah learn yes one cool thing with
JavaScript
this is imposed by tc39 guidelines is
anyone's need to make a decision about
how something is going to work it will
not change so for example the spread
operator the three dots that will
forever be structure things like it does
in es6 and when es seven and eight and
nine and wherever javascript goes in the
future the three dots will always be
structure just like objects can always
be accessed by the array blocks and by
dot notation those will not change and
that's a part of the way tc39 runs and
if you don't know tc39 is the like
people that make decisions about es6 in
the direction of the language and the
standards give descriptions about change
why what optional refactored yes six
challenges getting tested Thank You ade
nothing nothing cool get pushed origin
fix yes six challenges awesome alright
where can you get the code which I'm
doing right now yeah I cannot show you
guys the stuff he'd like I don't know if
this will let me post a link but here we
go
so that was the link to the github
challenge it's for this is the polar
quest pull request number 16 262 and
[Music]
that's where all my code is currently
sitting and then there's the challenge
and the years the where we are
addressing issue number 16 254 okay but
be right back guys
whoa
hello hello all right let's see one
question I always from learning one
framework in doing project with same
framework with new framework
I've journeyed you too so my I'm able to
learn in code in required framework yeah
I said it before but applying something
that you're learning is the best way to
its semester Olli oh yeah for sure you
don't ever need to fully master a
framework there's trust me there's
there's many aspects of free of react
that I still no clue and probably will
never use or maybe not total very small
you know in each case in the future but
that doesn't mean that I'm not that I
don't have that I'm not confident with
my react skills um just applying it keep
building project even when you're
learning is the best way to do it so
definitely keep it up alright let's get
back into it let's see what we got here
if you have any comments okay we got to
make sure we go back and test that one
good so the commit came through
everything is building correctly still
good to see
don't you know man get it
have fun you know I've never used I
think you meant to write couch I've
never used couch DB before unless
there's something called pouch DB but I
know there is one called couch electrons
a lot of fun and you know yeah there's
too much to know everything so just use
what you can keep building have fun with
it
no one's expecting you to just become a
master of one framework that's a little
crazy all right what are we doing with
this one ah right operator
think all we have to do here is go
change this to function and I think we
added out here that should fix it it's
right note I'll do it
oh well screw doing here pouch DB works
in the browser can sync with couchdb oh
cool yeah never I just know about them
I've never actually touched them I'm a
big fan of [ __ ] and firebase for a
while and now the new fire store um but
plenty good reasons to use other things
don't break on me
come on there we go oh that's not how
you write function
cool
oh cool interesting I like to keep that
in mind I was trying to I'm currently
thinking about a offline capable up yeah
can the steel store and read data from
pouch and when there is a network
connection to can sync with couch oh
cool
so I was gonna do something similar but
I was just gonna local storage at all
and then just using reacts thing
whenever the like the whenever the app
like loads up it would check the local
storage and be like yo is there
something in there if there is it would
like commit it to the database but
alright cool couch and couches sounds
fun do you guys know if it's a no SQL or
SQL base database or does it not matter
it's more of like a wrapper
Airbnb is popular Martin yeah go with
the Airbnb the standard es line options
are very standard and they actually get
changed quite often but no one's going
to be judging you based on your syntax
really as long as it's readable I would
also recommend looking into the prettier
project and using prettier TIF style
your code I've found that that is a lot
easier than using the es lint and doing
it manually
no well something's broken in here let's
see what it is
nope right here
oh nice girl awesome
is it a key value or document-based
databases are my like favorite thing in
the world I hope to study them more in
the future
why isn't nothing working here
nope that's not what I wanted if you're
gonna have just run the cop run the code
should know yeah
I'm prettier for matter for visual fruit
vs is a great one prettier just a
framework but you can um it kimete but
it's been like ported to like different
types of editors so you could just auto
pretty auto cliff eyes undefined why is
that undefined oh I failed I didn't even
do the tusks there we go there we go
that's it a change over here though
document based with JSON awesome best
book to learn data structures and
algorithms and JavaScript Oh friend let
me tell ya this one right here
introduction to algorithms I don't know
who it's by
but here
Thomas H Korman Charles Petersen Ronald
Rivest clifford stein highly recommend
not one and then data structures oh I
don't want to read it here we go fourth
edition data structures with
abstractions with Java Frank and Carano
Timothy and Henry two phenomenal books
they are textbooks college textbooks but
I best thing ever
you know there's David they don't get
any better than that that algorithms
textbook is like the best thing ever the
data structures one is you know it has
its pros and cons but yeah I was just
writing it down so if you wanted to copy
and paste be a little bit easier ok
we're on to the next one guys
for case is not defined good shouldn't
be
well just just because I just wanted to
pass but that was an easy fix
that needs to go get fixed real quick am
I crazy or yeah see this is wrong that
should get just in case ever someone
ever comes by and asks better
and this is the soon so Berkeley
approved on cool we'll get to that one
soon so you just made a basic edit over
here oh come on great and then was want
me to do it just wants me to do this
up there
oh that's an issue so see this who can't
do that here let's just return the right
crap okay gotta fix this one up let's
reclaim this function remove first - all
right have a good one Jessie have a have
a good night Himanshu glad you guys
enjoyed it thank you for thank you for
coming I hope it's not the last either
Himanshu I do well there's plenty of
these on free code camp so make sure to
come by in the future I'm glad
awesome
oh hi Sammy you're welcome for that
oh okay something went wrong
use destructuring in and out and that
can't do that
[Music]
get in there or get in there
we gotta grab all this code right here
apologies if you guys can hear the dogs
barking I think there's a boat coming by
are we actually easy to go out there now
this line gets to go up here instead
I'm so excited for these all to be ready
for everyone to run through themselves
all right
I'll start talking about what I was just
doing so basically three on semicolon
yes six an es five there's this awesome
mode called trick mode which basically
keeps things from going wrong doesn't it
it prevents the user from writing bad
code like rewriting over variables and
stuff now there are some rules with you
strict for example you're technically
not allowed to destructure variables or
assign defaults within a function
declaration of you're strict which is
what happens when you put you strict
within the function that you're gonna do
the destructuring in so by by doing what
I just did
hopefully uh a second way doing what I
just did this will still implement you
strict over this function but will then
still let us go ahead and do our D
structuring in inline so plus I
personally think this code looks pretty
baller awesome all right let me clean
this up a little bit before we move on
so wants a little look like that
what a space oh please don't I want to
paste that in do we want a space above
now we want it right up against it good
remove this line in one place right here
and then I'll put one more line in there
cool
all right we are moving right on through
know what's going on here get rid of
this console.log and replace it with a
white line white space right space we
should be golden actually
we go actually take this line and place
that one above it it's out there okay
so just any like that I wish to the week
this line I know what this one does so
we have to do a row or dot map and then
we're going to pass the value to this
template literal which is like class
equals text warning and then we're gonna
do the V in right there oh don't sit
syntax be right in there and then close
off this little thingamajig and get that
going there and we should be golden
we have to go ahead and then do cons to
self display array equals make less
result dot failure awesome snag this and
sneak it in right here
yes Martin an entire lesson section is
one JSON file the dream would be for it
to be way easier to edit but at the
moment this is what we're doing and it
does have a little bit of learning curve
but it ain't that bad once you get to
know it
okay
do we remove yeah I fixed everything
else up
nope every challenge is just one every
section is just one big JSON file the
JSON is processed and stored in a [ __ ]
database and then we take that [ __ ]
database and then that's what we pump
into the the client through like when
that when you want this page it goes and
reaches into MongoDB is like I want this
in the bills this challenge
what's the meaning of life
yes my the in here we actually it's like
when we want to build these code blocks
every new line is considered a entry
into the list and then you can also
input like HTML like block quote code HR
BR to break on the line when it comes to
the challenge seed this code is what's
rendered into here so the way you write
that is you use just you write your
JavaScript code but you have to put in
all your whitespace matters so it
actually holds its whitespace so like
you know you I have my indents here and
that is emulated on the screen when it
when it's rendered so did you get me
very deliberate with what you're right
otherwise it would be issues and this is
why we're refactoring and queuing and
using QA to make sure everything's good
yes Timo the custom editor for
challenges I wish that that existed and
I hope that someone have someone in the
future build one but for now this is the
old-fashioned way and hello nice seeing
ya mmm very tired
ah favorite challenge all right you guys
could see all the solutions
so this is past Fahrenheit to start and
then you get temperature
Yeah right yeah all right yeah this is
going to return this is returning
Celsius so you want 5.0
so I actually do not listen to lo-fi I
do enjoy it though but I'm actually
listening to a alternative playlist at
the moment I believe it's called good
vibes or something like or no I'm called
good future club they're like a company
and they have a playlist of a bunch of
alternative music shows into that when I
code I enjoy the the rhythm and the beat
to it it's just JavaScript you writing
yes yes it is JavaScript
this is es6 challenges for the upcoming
beta curriculum we are writing the we
are writing the challenges as well as
cueing them yes javascript is very
flexible it's a very loosely typed
language compared to Java but Java has a
special place in my heart because it it
reinforced some really good coding
practices for me that I get to emulate
with JavaScript and it helps a lot plus
algorithm and data structure design
using excuse me using Java was awesome
because I got to take full advantage of
all the object-oriented features like
inheritance encapsulation and
typesetting and all that wonderful stuff
iterators and private and public
variables made the most the most use out
of it and built some really awesome data
structures that had some really good use
cases and were really efficient so and
that would have been slightly harder
with JavaScript because you have to be
very cognizant of you know what you're
declaring and how you're using
everything that you declare all right
how we set temperature set temperature
receive Celsius so we want to say
I saw type out where is this one there
to stop
you know javascript does have classes it
is uh es seeks an es6 feature soon es5
but definitely less adapted but um nope
it has classes it kind of fakes it
though you know if you're actually
actually real quick so we're done we
just finished up the rest of these are
imports and requires and this section is
still broken so I'm not gonna try to QA
them at the moment which means let's
shut down go and shut down MongoDB and
let's quickly commit and I'm gonna show
you mean I'll go into a little bit about
es6 classes so we'll add this and then
npm run commit would be call this we
called this a fix no we called this
let's just fix it challenges refactor
you know we um QA remaining yes six
challenges yeah we don't need any of
that
all right that's good to go get push
origin fix yes six challenges so while
that while we wait for everything that
we're on on the background let me go
into a little bit detail about classes
for you you know so right now I'm
running an instance of Oh all right
never mind then can this work sorry hold
on a second
what's the command there we go that's
what I wanted all right cool we're clear
the console so we're looking at a node
console right now so we're gonna be able
to write JavaScript code you know that
if we right type of function you know
we'll get function your right type of
you know object you get object now if
you write type of clap or so let's now
let's define a class so we're gonna say
class C II just
Class C doesn't really have anything in
it so we write type of C it's called a
function so you notice type of C is a
function and that's the same as a
traditional function but then what if we
wrote type of new C oh well that's not
what I want to write type of new C it
gives us an object so what that what
this means is that classes in JavaScript
by default return an object but if you
notice if we wrote type of function here
let's do a self calling function so if
you when a default function in
JavaScript returns undefined because you
don't declared an a return statement
with abdu with classes it automatically
returns an object and this is built upon
because if you go ahead and you write
class c2 and then you add a constructor
that takes a variable foo and a variable
bar and then assigns them appropriately
you know act this dot x equals foo and
this dot y equals bar and then you close
everything off you can then go ahead and
do things like Const you know instance
equals new c2 you know a b c d e f and
then if you um class as a constructor
class has constructors it default it has
it you know it's default statement is
constructor because when you go ahead
and you use the new keyword on a class
it will automatically return it'll
automatically call the constructor so
what this means that instance now has an
X value an instance now has a Y value
and this you can take this further and
you can define functions and state and
you know if you go into react that's
where a lot of this awesome stuff comes
in and as you can see you can actually
go ahead and say type of c2 it's a
function type of c2 constructor he's
also a function type of new c2 is an
object and type of I believe if you do
this might not work
uh-huh so see if you try to call
constructor directly it doesn't exactly
work but yeah that's a brief intro into
classes
okay so let's go over here
so we refactored everything this should
refresh Internet
there we go and now we have one hmm one
more thing to do today let's go ahead
and check out these edits
um wait I forget how to do this yes
Maron so when you called type of and it
returns function it tells you that by
default the class is returning like it's
saying like here's my constructor
you know let me do something if you're
gonna check out
when you had to go do a race together
you get an empty string why beats me
it's a JavaScript thing we can actually
explore that you add two empty arrays
you get a string so if you think about
it type of that as an object so if you
were to add two objects together what do
you get Oh something ugly well I think
by default like an array returns would
probably return like its values so if
you had like you know they're gonna
write with something in it it would
wants to return itself and show you with
it so if this if these are empty less
considered like null entries or null
value or empty then when it adds
together it might just be returning like
its contents yeah it's all coercion
yes tema I want to I want to pull down
that PR locally I was just about to look
it up but if you know how to do it and
you want to share that would be
incredible do multi-class have multiple
constructors like overloading I don't
know if JavaScript does overloading
let's find out
class me only got lonely only have one
constructor in Java Script
who
I see okay yeah I found a team now it's
actually right here so I'm gonna check
check out B actually let me just copy
this and
okay good and then we should be able to
then run npm install get our stuff
this is a fun one guys check this out
this is the type coercion table so you
know true is the true false you know is
it false true is one true is also the
string one true is also the array
containing one you know null equals null
undefined equals undefined but they also
equal each other infinity only equals
infinity as well as negative the knee
only equals negative infinity but like
empty string is false it's also zero
it's also an empty string it's also an
empty array it's also a doubly nested of
D array okay install that and then we
should be able to run [ __ ]
where's this one yeah Rango
right which challenge do I want to test
this with declare read only variable
today you're wrong uh a second
this meant I meant to put sentence in
here
what
this is completely wrong put on suck
dies
can you post a link to that table yeah
let me grab it for you guys it doesn't
exactly like doing links in here so I'm
actually going to split it up and then
I'm just gonna let y'all connect it all
back together yeah we get links turned
off automatically cuz otherwise people
could post bad things but as the I think
I can just put that link back together
and y'all should be able to get to it
this has the old code nevermind I don't
think I'll be able to let me see if I
can do some magic
- whoa
crap this one and I should be able to do
what's wrong
this is not this ain't going well
alright this ain't going to work because
I'm gonna have to read well let me see
if I can know around you guys
we are going to go rogue here and we're
gonna do some real fun get stuff alright
so what just popped up on screen is from
the amazing Dan Abramov from react and
he taught me how to basically keep
something up-to-date but it also has
some really fun things in it like how to
reset something back to its original
state which is a very useful tool useful
thing to know how to do so we're first
of all we're just gonna reset hard to
scissors need food to fix loop pro tect
undefined error that did not work I
think I forgot nope
I just get reset
there we go
yeah so all these issues are all right
so we're just gonna basically close
we're just gonna get checkout earth
sorry and get checkout fix es6 yeah
getting sloppy okay cool
used to be I'm a little confused
it's just not gonna let me on desk in
digital code I think this is good okay
in this spelled fix where Oh before yeah
probably
outside check out spelled incorrectly um
can I get removed the branch how do i I
just want - oh you always gotta look
your stuff up when you're doing get you
never want to just go for it because you
could break things get removed branch
Dulli a local branch cool okay let's get
that branch name back up I just do get
check out Dee right now we got a right
branch hello how you doing today we're
just cleaning up here having some fun
with git
some other ones why don't we just clean
up I'll clean up a little bit of my
thank you very much and oh okay I
misspelled it in the reset all right
it's whatever I was I needed a
cherry-pick like four different commits
and that wasn't gonna happen so what I'm
gonna do is I'm doing a little cleanup
and then I'm going to go and squash my
commits for the ESX challengers into one
and then I'm gonna re fork the thing
that I just grabbed and then I should be
able to cherry pick that singular commit
and then merge all new do the whole
thing run the database all that and then
I should should be able to test my new
challenges with that loopback fix so I
just need to just trying to do some
cleanup and I should be able to now
because I believe the feature one we
merged last night awesome
okay so never run get branch good that's
all I want to see okay so now give me a
moment we're going to open a new mozilla
window you guys don't need to see that
perfect it's over here and now we're
gonna run some other fun ones so first
of all we're gonna get log the the
commits for my last for the last four
commits that I have
that did not work what did I miss an
owner vision or path not in the working
tree maybe we'll do that oh no that's
not what I wanted to - oh God nope still
not right what is right get log maybe
I'll look at the last few so you have QA
remaining challenges QA es6 challenges
refactor es6 challenges and then add
function scope of you strict those are
the four yep cool so now we want to get
rebase I head and we want to do the sub
we want to grab the last four so this
grabs the previous three plus the parent
does it now I did not
okay so then I just quickly have to run
just escape out just quit without saving
your the four there we go and then we're
gonna go ahead and just call squash on
all these wait we got to pick first
so that's the first one we pick and then
we squash the rest into
into the first one and what this does is
takes all the changes that I made up
till now and pushes it all into one
commit dot instead of that that probably
is it Timo what is all of that okay so
this is github this is like how I make
changes to this is how we track all the
changes and what you're looking at is
the logs of all the work that we've done
so far so in this for the past 12 hours
I have created four different commits on
the code that on these es6 challenges
and those are four separate things like
they're called like diffs like di FF
differences what I'm doing right now is
I'm taking all three and compressing
them into one and that then that one
difference can be merged at once and
then I can also take that big difference
that one singly difference and plop it
onto another branch which is what I plan
to do in the next step because we want
to test someone else's code on our
challenges to make sure that challenge
works the way you do all that is you
have a squash commits and that's we're
doing right now so we just edited the
the commit history and we've added the
squash commands and then once we've done
that we can then escape and then do
right quit good this is a combination of
four commits good we just want to scroll
through it the cut the hash lines are
comments they don't get printed be
ignored
great last commands done
I love it okay golden so now we need to
get push force the origin yes six
challenges great and if everything went
correctly this should have reset the
history here and it did not Oh missed
one step I don't know what it was oh
wait here we go
okay so now you'll see all of my code
has just been compressed into a singular
commit so all 178 plus all the 123
differences is one singular commit if
you go and click on the commit you'll
notice that it actually has the previous
three can that's in here this is a what
it looks like so what is this all about
basically these this is the kind of a
higher-level get function which
maintains the state of a repository and
it easier way let's pretend that this
this PR right here was to get merged
into the project with four different
commits in it but something went wrong
you know something broke in the and we
broke the main the staging that the
production level application because we
merge from this pull request we would
have to go back and revert the four
commits that we merged four times
manually with each different commit code
and that's a process that's annoying
instead before we merge this whole chunk
of code into the main project we squash
everything into a singular commit one
code change it's called we make it we
tell
Virgen control system here that
everything we've done we want to commit
all at once instead of in bits and
pieces so if let's say we now work now
we merge this pull request with one
singular commit and something went wrong
on the staging side all we would have to
do is reverse this single commit all the
changes would be removed and we'd be
okay and we are maintaining the history
here because there's an a big aspect of
the history of things that have been
changed so people can know who changed
what when so by rebasing and doing all
that squashing and stuff that i just did
in the command line we have this
beautiful you know this really easy to
read descriptive commit definition along
with you know all our code changes
bundle into one okay that was kind of a
long explanation and it comes with a
reason because we're also about to do
something cool so I'm gonna go over back
over to here I'm going to copy this and
we're gonna go ahead and run it great
now I want to get cherry-pick
my singular commit yes it does need to
get approved I will not be merging it
until Quincy or Betsy or Berkeley or
anyone Teemo or anyone else reviews my
code and tells me it's all good
cool so we just cherry picked and you
guys noticed that we just changed
everything in this file in one click
with no merge conflicts so happy it's a
good sign
now what we have to do is run NPM
install and then we should be able to
run [ __ ] dos um one was running this
one's been running the whole time that's
not good oops let's go ahead and just go
back to one and we're gonna write [ __ ]
and then we're gonna create a new tab
and run node seed and then we run gulp
awesome and then we get to go back over
here do a nice hard refresh on here
I might have to clear local storage
we'll see it's working it's working yes
and we unlock the code run it passes no
loopback errors so now we can go back
and we can say let's go ahead and let's
quit gulp and quit out of [ __ ] then
let's go get checkout back to our fix on
es6 challenges and then I'm not touching
that
that's not put on just one second guys
get branch I'd like to just
modified package lock JSON that's not a
good sign just gonna get reset don't
know why that's acting up oh I have to
rerun NPM install that's fine
honestly that doesn't really matter that
much because we've already changed it
online and wants to get to merge up
there we're good so we're good over here
get rid of this this challenge is great
and ready for QA and then we can go back
over here and we can say let's let's
code this out and let's say completed
and successful update the comment and
then I'm gonna go over here and I'm
going to say I'm going to go ahead and
approve approve
and we should be good to squash and
merge because Berkeley approved that
I've approved it Quincy approved it
squash and marriage awesome great work
great work on this was able to run my
new changes to es6 curriculum and get
the loopback error to go away loop
protect cool so this is the so that
we've done that and now we can go over
here which we refresh that should merge
that should say merged and now this gets
closed automatically and we get
committed together
some awesome let's refresh this so this
is the issue that is going to get closed
when this one gets closed and if we
refresh this we should get a green light
so I'm gonna do this I'm gonna say
change this to the checkmark qaid
locally on live stream update the
comment so this will close that issue
Quincy stuff got solved I've done this
completed and successful and add
function scope to use strict verifies so
now all that someone has to come through
is come and check everything and then
squash and merge when they're ready to
go and our changes get successfully done
with that only run get status again this
package out lock is still being weird
so I'll figure that out on my own time
but with that guys I think we're done
for today if you have any other
questions I'm down to hang around and
answer some stuff but yeah that was a
crazy amount of work both coding and
with get I'd be happy to do to go over
what I've done again and talk more about
it and share some of my resources so I'm
let me know I'll hang around for a few
more minutes and then I'll then after
that I'll sign off and all that good
stuff
they're right I don't see anything in
the comments so I'll take that as time
to head out so guys thank you so much
for coming today I love doing these
streams expect more from them in the
future have a wonderful day
happy coding please reach out if you
need anything or assistance or help or
guidance be happy to give it with that
have it going guys